make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with the swords of x event and this sees
the return
of one of my favorite villains of all
time in the history
of marvel comics you guys know exactly
who i'm talking about
the downside of this is we see him once
that's all we get so what we initially
have here is an emissary right an
invitation to a contest of worlds
basically saying we invite you to see
the the battle between the forces of
morocco and the forces of krakowa now a
lot of you guys have kind of been
wondering
or at least kind of expressed a little
bit of confusion in terms of what's
going on here to kind of sum this all
down the nature of what's going on with
x of swords or i guess ten of swords
whatever you want to call it the whole
reason why this is taking place
is because apocalypse when he opened the
gate the external gate that basically
allows access between krakowa
and other world his goal was to use that
gate to access a rocco
to rescue his wife and his children the
four horsemen and then bring them back
to krakowa and basically unite his
family what he ended up discovering and
what we discovered
is that what you also had going on were
called the forces of ammon and the
forces of amith managed to breach their
own realm and then eventually they were
taken over by the four horsemen so the
four horsemen lead the army of
ammon and so when apocalypse entered
other world with the intention of
reuniting his family that he discovered
his family had basically become bad guys
right like his his kids
basically became villains and they were
leading this army and they intended to
basically use the curcumin gate they
granted access to otherworld to pass
through that
gate into krakowa and then conquer kokoa
and the rest of the world
right so it was it's kind of like you
know i want to get my kids back oh my
god they're villains and the whole
reason why this matters is because in
order to settle the affair right in
order to basically keep like all-out war
between the forces of krakowa and the
forces of morocco emerging
uh saturnine basically created this
contest right created this this whole
great big huge tournament and whoever
wins will be the one who decides or who
kind of gets what it is that they want
right so if the four horsemen if
apocalypse apocalypse's kids win the
tournament then they lead the army of
ammon
into krakowa if the forces of corcola
win then the army of ammon whatever
happens to them happens to them
and that's why we are where we are right
now just a quick little synopsis kind of
a quick explanation
i get that some of you guys are a little
confusing it's the nature of going
through jonathan hickman's work kind of
piece by piece
is that it's one of these things where
he reads much better in trade
it's much much better to read jonathan
hickman's stories when it's all done
and you go and you get the trade
paperbacks right it makes everything
make a lot more sense but
the uh the emissary has basically
appeared here to mad jim jasper's in the
crooked market right and basically
saying
this is your invitation to show up here
to this tournament to become a part of
it right to kind of watch everything
unfold
and that's the last time we see jim
jasper's in this comic but here's the
funny thing about this right here's the
funny thing about what hickman's gonna
end up doing here
jonathan hickman with with matt jim
jasper's it could go one of two ways
right we could see mad jim jasper's pop
off we could see him just
lose his mind and this crazy display of
power in the next issue
we may not see him again for another
five issues right it could be that we
see him in like the background during
the whole tournament and then we don't
actually see him do anything
for another 50 issues there's no telling
with jonathan hickman right we have no
idea
jonathan hickman writes for the long
game right he writes for the conclusion
of the story so
it's kind of the nature of the beast
right it's the nature of these things
and so
because of that the next thing is that
the the emissary visits the kingdom of
uh siboleth and then of course visits
the infuria at the everforge now the
infuria and really the fury themselves
the fact that there's more than one
is kind of terrifying the fury are
wildly powerful beings right so
to kind of give you guys a little bit of
an explanation here when mad jim jaspers
originally appeared in marvel comics he
was part of a universe called earth 238
and this was a universe where he
basically
killed all the superheroes but jim
jaspers didn't do it on his own
instead what he did is he used his
powers to warp reality
to create the fury and the fury was a
being that had the ability to adapt to
anybody's powers
and then overcome them it's how the fury
was able to defeat jim jaspers from the
main marvel universe when the fury
showed up
inside the main marvel universe or at
least the first time the fury killed him
the two of them actually ended up coming
back there's a story that we haven't
covered
called x-men die by the sword i think
where jim jasper's comes back
but uh but the whole idea here is that
the fury
realized that the only way that jim
jasper's powers work is if he has a
universe to alter
and so he took him to where the earth
238 universe was at before it was
destroyed
and then basically obliterated him right
because he realized that in this giant
empty space where there is no matter
that jim jasper's is powerless
right so the fact that there's like an
entire place here full of furies
is kind of nuts they are weapon forgers
they create like these basically
basically like these unbreakable weapons
in all of reality like in the entirety
of the multiverse because remember what
we're dealing with here are multiversal
locations
people from different universes can
access these different places like the
qriket market
apocalypse from like you know the age of
apocalypse universe could access this
and like characters from like the days
of future past universe could access
this
feasibly if they decided to include it
the marvel cinematic universe dr
strange could travel to this place right
let's it's kind of kind of bonkers so
we're dealing with things in a much
larger scale these aren't planets these
are whole universal territories right
little pocket dimensions you've also got
the holy republic of the fae you've got
the floating kingdom of roma
uh romo regina this is basically merlin
and uh and roma they were
previously the ones who ruled over
otherworld before the events of the
incursions the death of the
uh of the whole uh captain britain corps
and the fact that they just kind of
ended up going to war with each other
but in their absence it allowed
saturnine to take over control of
otherworld and that's why she is where
she is uh but nonetheless
you know following these these kind of
emissaries or this emissary that's sent
out and these invitations that are given
to these various people
we pick up with what are called the foul
and fair courts and this is basically a
kind of coming together of these various
courts
some of which we see here some of which
we don't for example you don't see
jim jasper's here who's considered part
of the foul court probably because he's
just like i have other things to do
besides show up here you see the furies
who are here they're considered part of
the fair court hickman doesn't really
play it solid insofar as saying
the fair court are good guys the foul
court or bad guys we're not really given
a given a kind of
knock down explanation that way we can
kind of assume maybe it is but
historically merlin is a dick and the
fact that he's part of the
of the foul court kind of makes sense
but roma's been a little
you know weird too sometimes and so
there's been a few times where she's
been a little bit villainous in her
actions and so
again it kind of seems to follow that
ideology but again we're not given like
an actual definitive explanation here
instead the whole purpose behind the
assembling of this court is basically
for the blights
blight spokes to be allowed access
across like any of the dimensions that
they want to now we're not really given
a whole lot of information about the
blight spoke and in fact this is all we
really seem to see of them right you got
sheriff uh geo white chapel of the
blight spoke and that's really it uh
their request is denied and that's
that's really all you get here but it's
a little bit of kind of a court thing
but the reason why hickman does this
is because this will be important later
on down the line right there's a reason
why he gives us this and so for the most
part we can kind of take this little bit
of a scene we can sit it on the back
burner and then come back to it at a
future point in time uh but the the
important thing to kind of come out of
this is that at the at the conclusion of
this meeting
essentially you end up having saturnine
who asks the the current horsemen who
were there uh you know
like pestilence and war are you were
rocco forces currently prepared
to engage in this conflict and their
answer is yes and then of course she
asked jamie braddock what about your
forces like gracoa and he's like they're
on their way right so basically this is
a coming together of the warriors right
they're all basically arriving
in other world and then the tournament
will commence after that right and so
when what we end up doing here is
transitioning to gracoa and apocalypse
talking to all the the sword bearers
right and he gives like the worst
speech ever he's like okay guys don't
die because if you do
then you're gonna come back in some
weird twisted version all right let's go
and that's basically it and instead you
know the the statement's kind of like
i mean you should kind of give us a
little bit of like a pep talk
right i mean you know it's like like
literally uh like cable's like i mean
can you like
it couldn't hurt right if you give us
some kind of a pep talk and so he does
and it's actually this epic pep talk
right he says like sword bears most of
you
are mutant you have tasted the sweetness
of immortality and evolution of our
people meaning the fact that they can
die and always come back
now we step into the other world where
all realities are won
and your defeat will mean the death of
kercoa the death of this earth and the
death of you
as you are now never to return so when
you draw your sword
you must not fight like a human who
stands to lose
a few years of toil but like a mutant
who stands to lose
forever in paradise for if you do not
you will not be the first immortals i
will have watched
die it's a crazy it's a really really
cool thing
it's a pretty epic speech right it's a
pretty awesome speech there
and so what we end up doing is picking
up with these various forces of gracoa
and derocco
all showing up here right and initially
it starts with captain britain showing
up here along wolverine cable so on they
all basically teleport in at the same
time
but when they do it's kind of like okay
like they're immediately on their guard
right because they don't know if they're
teleporting in here
and the battle immediately starts they
don't know if they're teleporting in
here and there's gonna be a lot of pomp
and circumstance right a great big huge
kind of procession or
you know kind of welcome to the the tin
fx event you know and so on and so forth
you know and like you got michael buffer
there you know
in this side of the ring standing at
five foot two
weighing some ridiculous number because
his bones are covered in
an unbreakable metal wolverine like we
don't really know
if that's that's that's what we're gonna
get right i think it'd be awesome
if like michael buffer showed up here
and offered a kind of speech but i think
it'd be pretty cool
but saturday finally makes your
appearance and basically tells everybody
you guys need to chill right you know
like like relax the tournament's not
starting yet
it will start soon your fellow
combatants are going to be arriving here
and it'll be a chance for you guys to
meet so
head to your quarters they've all been
prepared for you and when they arrive
there they're all given their respective
cards
remember these were cards that were
created by saturnine explicitly for them
but the cards do not necessarily mean
what they appear to be on their faces
for example
uh you end up having cable who's given
the card of the fool and it doesn't mean
the cable is an actual fool even though
he thinks that's what it means
instead it's the journey of the fool
which is to say he doesn't know
everything yet but he will learn a lot
as time goes on
this really kind of seems to be a
roundabout way of jonathan hickman
saying
the powers of cable are going to expand
or cable's own individual story is going
to become a lot more grandiose than it
currently is but then of course you end
up having apocalypse who reads his
gets angry and throws it away and so
what he ends up doing is traveling to
meet saturnine and this common a
conversation between these two
is wildly intriguing and that's what
makes hickman's you know
ex of swords so cool it's because you
see characters meeting
whom you would never see meet under any
other circumstance and watching how they
interact is
really intriguing for example like
saturnine was never really the most
powerful character ever it wasn't until
she took over otherworld and then
started using all the magics at its
disposal
to to to utilize you know to really rule
this place that she became as powerful
as she is
prior to this she was basically a
figurehead right she was the omniversal
magistrates she was not on par with like
the living
tribunal or something like that she just
kind of played more of a gubernatorial
role in relation to like how the
multiverse functions you know if you
kind of broke it down into different
positions she played more of the
governing body
uh with regards to the living tribunal
he played like the power source now
neither one really associated with the
other it's not like you would see
meetings of the omniversal development
court and like the living tribunals out
there in the third row watching it all
go down you would never really see that
instead it was just it was kind of doing
its own thing it was part of this wildly
intricate hierarchy
of how the multiverse you know how its
form and function is maintained the
funny thing about that though is
the omniversal development court was
sometimes acknowledged and sometimes
ignored by marvel comics depending on
who the writer was you know for example
you never really hadn't seen it for like
i want to say it didn't appear for like
a decade
until you got to the incursions right i
mean you had spider-man uk
and you had a few appearances here and
there but like in those five years that
marvel was leading up to secret wars you
saw it multitude
a multitude of times prior to that you
never really saw it at all right
and you probably wouldn't have known it
existed unless you were reading the
right kind of comics uh and even then it
didn't really appear all that often in
excalibur so it's one of these
interesting things
that's kind of the nature of the nature
of how it all works marvel's never
really consolidated it they never really
kind of explained like what's the nature
of the omniversal development court in
comparison to the living tribunal does
like the one above all is he part of
this like was he was he the one that
kind of engineered that how does it
compare to like the fulcrum and the neil
gaiman comics for for the eternals we
don't really know right we're not really
giving an explanation here uh but with
apocalypse showing up here and basically
meeting her
the question is i don't really like what
what i'm seeing here right like i don't
really like what's going on i don't
really like this game you're playing
answer me right like what's the meaning
of these taunts of all this nonsense but
notice
saturnine doesn't really take him
seriously now one of the big things
about her character about saturnine's
character historically is she always had
a kind of arrogance right there was
always a kind of arrogance about her in
the sense of
i'm above you i'm way above i'm way you
know much higher above you
than anybody else is right you know it's
just the nature of things you know in
terms of power
probably not or at least you know before
she became ruler of other worlds she's
nowhere near above apocalypse but even
apocalypse plays a little haughty right
he's like answering me before you know
explain yourself before i become angry
well he's literally in the in the like
he's in the lion's den right he's in the
belly of the beast what is he gonna do
like there's no power he possesses that
could overcome saturnine
i guess maybe he could just start like
smashing the twilight citadel right just
like
you know smashing his fists and knocking
off giant chunks of it and just more or
less like inconveniencing her but that
would be about it
that'd be about all that he could do in
this situation but one of the things she
says is she's like i'm kind of intrigued
by you
you really are one of the oldest beings
in existence right in in you know on
your earth not across your entire
universe right relative to the history
of the universe you're but a speck where
you've been you've been alive for a
fraction of a second but in terms of the
history of your earth you've been around
for a relatively lengthy amount of time
i mean even within the history of the
earth right it's still kind of a
fraction of a second but in comparison
to the evolution of your race of mutant
kind you've been around for a long long
time and even in comparison to the
length of humanity you've been around
for a pretty lengthy amount of time but
i'm interested i'm kind of curious about
you right all this power that you
possess
you beat morgan le fay right in like a
straight up battle that's
interesting but what you've done here is
you've bullied yourself
in you've basically played the role of
somebody who's lesser than yourself and
was once it was all said and done
the only reason you even got here is
because i invited you so ask yourself
the question
is it kind of an insult to know that no
matter what your best efforts were
you only got in here because i allowed
it but even kind of continuing this
taunting and even when he says like are
you trying to provoke me you know at the
end of the day
she still just kind of plays it fast and
loose and she still doesn't really take
him uh
take him seriously more so than that
she's like you're a very very old being
i'm surprised that you're acting so
impatient here you really shouldn't be
acting this impatient right you've been
around long enough you should have more
patience than almost anybody else here
you're playing a game that you've been
working on for millennia and here at the
finish line you're going to suddenly
grow impatient but the funny thing about
this is that it reveals the very human
side of apocalypse in the sense of
of course he does like he's just about
done like which one of us doesn't find
our second wind when we're that close to
the finish line right
that's kind of where he is you know this
kind of new method this new step of
zealousness that's going on with this
character and so with saturnine who is
already on her way to a meeting she
invites apocalypse along and this is one
of those things where it seems to be
kind of designed
to more or less play games but when he
enters into this meeting room he's met
by an individual who is wearing what's
basically the
the helmet of ammonth the helmet uh the
helmet of this of this demon entity and
as we explained in the last video
those individuals who wear it become the
voice of amith itself i really say
itself because we don't really know if
this demon is like a man or a woman or
anything about them whatsoever
but they basically become the person or
kind of stand in as a person who's
leading this whole force right and so
this person that she's meeting with is
effectively the person who's leading the
four horsemen who in turn
are leading the army of ammon right so
this person is basically apocalypse's
enemy because we we know
that by virtue of the various swords and
who's gonna be fighting who that
apocalypse
is destined to fight this person and
when this person goes and removes their
mask
we one see the card of apocalypse that
says the lovers
and then two it's apocalypse's wife it's
genesis
this means that during the tournament
apocalypse is going to have to fight
and he's going to have to kill his wife
this is a
bold move by saturnine because if it
goes awry say for example the genesis is
a turn code say for example that she's
operating under this role
but isn't actually allied with ammon or
her children the four horsemen and is
actually working directly alongside
apocalypse because remember they had
that conversation before she went to the
portal
prepare the world for what's coming if
she really has maintained her solitude
all this time and she really is a good
guy
all this time then things could pop off
fast it could pop
off so quickly and go south so
astronomically fast right there's
there's no telling what's gonna happen
here but i know
i know it doesn't seem overly surprising
i know it doesn't seem like this great
big huge crazy grandiose event but this
right here
could easily turn into the turn of the
tide and everything saturnine's built
could come crashing down but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comics explained make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you